I'm very happy to make as my talk at the
table the exciting announcement of a new
addition to our team here at CBS News
and CBS mornings that is award-winning
journalist Lisa Ling she has been named
a CBS News contributor uh most recently
if you haven't been following her work
she was the executive producer uh and
star Storyteller I think that's a fair
term for what she did with uh life or
this is life with Lisa Lang it ran for
eight years on CNN she's reported on
dozens of topics over the years
everything from gun violence to Asian
American history and from dozens of
countries as well she will make her CBS
News debut later this summer she'll be
based in Los Angeles
um you know I came from print journalism
before TV and when I was making the
transition Lisa's stuff is one of she's
one of the people I would watch her
stuff and they say good artists borrow
great artist steal I was definitely
stealing some Lisa Lane making some
notes yeah I was like how does she do
this uh you know she says she can't
think of a better home for her style of
reporting than CBS News we're all very
honored or say that it's great for us
we're grateful to have her yeah
congratulations to her congratulations
to us